desde yakarta hasta seúl pasando por
Wellington
protestas mundiales coordinadas contra
el cambio climático se desplegaron en
las calles organizadas por el movimiento
juvenil friders for Future al igual que
muchas otras en todo el mundo
esta estudiante de secundaria en seúl
faltó a clase para estar allí
ya puede ser mi casa la que se inunde
estoy viviendo con una sensación de
crisis entonces creo que es más
importante llevar mis inquietudes al
gobierno para que tome medidas
preventivas que ir a la escuela lo
importante para mí en este momento no es
una prueba escolar para mí sobrevivir es
la verdadera prueba
70 ciudades italianas participaron
expresando su frustración por la falta
de acción ambiental antes de las
elecciones generales del país el domingo
hay muy pocas políticas sobre el clima y
su salvaguarda en última instancia
esperamos lograr una transición
ecológica total
los políticos no nos han escuchado
todavía no nos escuchan y es poco
probable que lo hagan
los científicos advierten que los países
no están haciendo lo suficiente para
cumplir el objetivo principal del
acuerdo climático de París de 2015
limitar el aumento del calentamiento
global a 1.5 grados centígrados este
siglo En comparación con la época
preindustrial
los objetivos prometidos
cumpliendo en absoluto Y eso no puede
ser personas de todo el mundo están
sufriendo esta crisis y empeorará si no
actuamos a tiempo esto en momentos en
los que la crisis energética causada por
la invasión rusa a Ucrania ha obligado a
los países europeos a reactivar las
plantas de Carbón y Volver al fracking
para la obtención de gas de exquisito un
retroceso para la lucha contra el cambio
climático que el planeta no se puede
permitir